so to kick off the Year we're hosting a
free live stream this Thursday January
the 11th at 700 p.m. central Time this
is the biggest live stream we've ever
done it's over 300,000 folks already
registered it's me Dr John deloney
Rachel Cruz George camel to my right
Jade warshaw all going to be talking
about navigating money anxiety breaking
the cycle breaking the orbital pool of
stupid bad money habits that keep you
stuck practical money tips that actually
work and for the first time remember
we're going to give away $10,000 10
people are going to win $1,000 each as
you are a viewer not signed up you are
actually viewing because we will put it
up there and you will have to be
watching at that moment to qualify so
you need to be watching and signing up
to do this go to ramsy solutions.com
breakthe cycle and register